die schmuggelzigaretten und erpresst
schutz gelte die vietnamesen mafia vor
einem jahr dann ein spektakulärer
fahndungserfolg die polizei schnappt
einen 53 jahre alten vietnamesen in prag
er soll am 30 juli 1995 also vor 25
jahren
zwei brüder 16 und 22 jahre alt in einem
wohnzimmer in chemnitz erdrosselt haben
seitdem war er spurlos verschwunden
heute soll endlich das urteil fällen
fallen
wir wollen wissen wie funktioniert diese
mafia bei mir im studio ist jetzt im
matthias becker hallo matthias du kennt
sich mit denen ja mit der mafia aus weil
du da seit jahren recherchiert in diesem
umfeld wie groß ist denn die
vietnamesische mafia hier in deutschland
bei uns sie agiert im verborgenen
niemand weiß ihre genaue anzahl man muss
auch wissen dass mafia größen und auch
deren handlanger alle über mehrfach
identitäten verfügen also sie haben 34
teilweise sogar fünf pässe und von daher
kann niemand ihre genaue zahl bestimmen
und in welchen bereichen ob er die mafia
ja das ist alles was mit schmuggel und
geld zu tun hat menschen zigaretten
zwangsprostitution aber auch geldwäsche
ist ein ganz großes delikt fällt und was
unterscheidet jetzt diese mafia von
anderen kriminellen netzwerken
sie sind extrem brutal die hochphase
beim mitte der 90er jahre so wie jetzt
auch im prozess wieder es hoch kommt da
sind menschen jagten in ausländer heim
vollzogen worden wir hatten den
höhepunkt 95 mit dem mazana massaker mit
sechs toten oder ermordeten menschen der
hauptpost damals in berlin wie der bau
der hat er den spitznamen der
barmherzige klingt sehr skurril ist es
auch der ist noch heute in strafhaft
hier in berlin-tegel und schreibt jetzt
mittlerweile liebesgedichte